hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and I'm making this quick video just to
talk a bit about Delta in the order flow
you know there's three basic building
blocks I think to order flow one of
which is Delta the other is point of
control and the other is imbalances but
I want to talk about today is
recognizing things in the Delta that can
help your trading now before I begin you
know brief disclaimer basically don't
trade with money you can't afford to
lose you know training is not for
everybody and just really quick you know
the order flow software that I use in
this video is my software the order
flows trader which is available from
order flows com so Delta is what it is
if you're new to order flow basically
it's the difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in the bar
every bar has a delta it could be
positive or negative and on rare
occasion it's going to be zero not just
because it lands on zero I don't think
it means anything
you know it's just coincidence it could
have landed on minus one it could omit
landed on plus one you know sometimes
people that are new to order flow they
hear the term in Delta and immediately
they start thinking about options and
Delta in as its applied to options this
is not the same this is different it's a
way to measure aggressive activity in a
bar and when a trader buys at the market
basically buys the best offer it
registers as class 1 in the Delta when a
trader sells at the market
he sells into the best bid it registers
as minus 1 now when a bar has positive
Delta generally aggressive buyers are in
control of that bar when a bar has
negative Delta generally aggressive
sellers are in control I say generally
because that's not always the case but
I'll be talking about today is how Delta
is a market generated piece of
information that's going to help a
trader determine times when demand is
weakening and times when supply is
weakening now will tell you exactly
every single time supply is weakening or
demand is weakening no but there are
times when it is so clear that
overlooking it would be stupid alright
so let me pull up a chart here really
quick so what I got here so this is e
minis this is a one-minute chart and on
my software you know it's on the bottom
right Delta here now there's there's
other software's out there if you're
using something else fine just know
where you can find your Delta the same
type of analysis
will apply personally I'm so used to
looking at it at the bottom that if I
had it above some software puts it above
or below the bars it to me it just gets
more confusing I just like it nice and
neatly lined up underneath the bar at
the bottom so I could see it at a glance
now like I said yeah every bar is going
to have a delta it's either gonna be
positive or negative and generally as
the markets moving down it's gonna move
down on negative Delta when a market is
moving up its going to move up on
positive Delta but what I was talking
about how you can determine if supply is
weakening or demand is weakening is when
you start analyzing the Delta as you
know sort of well it's not as a whole
but as you know you string them together
I guess is the best way to put it
so for example here right this market is
going down okay you got a swing high up
here it's starting to sell off a bit you
know swing high at 78 and a half comes
down to 71 and a half okay but what's
happening in this Delta you know on the
way down it's got strong Delta it's got
that big strong Delta number here minus
eight ninety five you know this big red
bar appears minus 1174 so obviously
sellers are in control here sellers are
definitely in control here strong
sellers here - 351 - 402 - 900 we're
still going down right still got this
negative Delta's sure you have some
positive good bars with positive Delta's
in here 150 it's kind of small 393 yeah
okay doesn't necessarily mean this moves
over but what I'm really looking at is
as we're coming down as we make a move
right if you're looking for in this case
supply to be weakening and for a market
to make a reversal you got to have a
move to reverse right so if what I'm
looking for is in the Delta is something
like this right you see the Delta sort
of contracting here - 939 - 661 - 193
then it's positive buyers are coming in
here plus 324 now again - 551 is strong
- 70 though you know there's a green bar
and then plus 325 plus 94 plus 10 76 so
at this point down in here when I see
this Delta when I see this formation so
to speak this pattern - 931 - 6 6 1 -
and then flips the positive 324 this is
telling me that as we were coming down
into this low a potential law was being
put in here - 193 is less than obviously
well it's not less than it's actually
more than because you're doing a
negative number so instead of the Delta
getting stronger with aggressive sellers
being more in control and gressive
sellers are weakening - 939 - 6 6 1 -
193 right it's the selling is not as
strong as an aggressive buying coming in
here now you got this one bar here - 551
granted you okay well maybe this moves
not over then you gotta watch what's
happening in the next bars you can't
just say well I got this bar here with -
551 Delta even though we got a higher
low than the low down here and just say
well this moves not over we're still
going down no you gotta watch what
happens afterwards right you know if
you're getting long off this bar right
you this - 931 939 - 661 - 193 + 324 for
getting long in here you don't know at
this time that this bar is gonna close
at - 551 you're long in here you know
your stop is just below this low
somewhere down here
so you're basically risking this little
area down here you know how many two
points you know where's your target your
targets gonna be somewhere up in here
around the 78 area 77 area and so you
see the negative Delta you start
thinking oh no you know I'm wrong and
also we got a big sellers coming in but
the fact that we haven't taken out the
low the previous bar the low of the
previous bar is still encouraging then
this next bar comes in you take off the
low the previous bar but still up above
the these two bars right off the low
then the market starts making reverse'
tea in its course right you got the
small Delta up - seventy then you got
here plus 325 plus 94 plus 1076 up up up
back up to the 70 you know whatever that
is 78 area somebody ate in a quarter
area okay now you know a little bit
later
you got same sort of thing happening
here so you know up here at 78 you sell
off boom boom boom you're coming down
you get down to this area
okay now on these bars down here right
you see the deltas all negative on this
move down minus 95 minus 1100 minus 1900
minus 360 minus 567 - 687 - 651 - forty
okay but it's still negative minus 280 -
I'm not yet convinced that you know I
should be buying in here yet when I see
a sign of aggressive buyers coming in in
positive Delta then you know that would
be like sort of my ghost signal and you
don't get it till over here so it's -
1049 - 579 - 92 then boom the aggressive
buyers come in here you can see a
positive Delta of 420 - you know you got
multiple imbalances in here you got
stacked vine and balanced in here you
know you got a lot of nice things going
in this bar and you see how the market
just you know it makes this nice move
back up doesn't quite get up to 78
immediately up here you only gets up to
76 but you know what that's a decent
trade you know that's still five points
in the ESPYs alright so what does it
look like when you're up near high so
this is the eighth around 7:15 at night
so you know you can use this during the
day session you can use it in the
evening session and this is a perfect
example right so we're here at our highs
up here twenty-nine thirty five and
three quarters you know we just keep
hitting those highs he's not a many one
minute chart but you'll notice as you
get up in here right Delta okay so the
first time you break out to the new high
is positive Delta 479 then so small
negative Delta's - 69 - 29 strong Delta
still - 96 but we still can't get past
this high next bar strong you know
positive Delta I don't say strong Delta
182 again we just hit that high don't
get past it next bar little inside bar
positive Delta 23 small next bar up bar
was a negative Delta 48 next bar we hit
that high again Delta a positive Delta
of 80 then the next bar a little bit
lower positive Delta 54 then third bar
here 14 are then strong sellers minus
133 now what's interesting in here right
if you're looking you got 296 1:8
2:23 the -48 and then again positive
80-54 14 minus 133 where's your
aggressive buyers where's the buyers to
take this market higher you don't see
them instead you've seen this buying
really weakening up here every time you
poke up to the hi it's on weaker
positive Delta and then as you just sort
of hanging around the hi each bar is
putting in weaker Delta weaker positive
Delta finally what does the market do
well look at this it sells off from this
area up in here around the 34 area down
into you know down to or you down here
28 or we just sort of start going
sideways down here so you know whether
you're looking at it from a bottoming
aspect or a top being put in you know
watch what's happening in the Delta you
know put the pieces together of order
for trying to figure out okay well
what's the market telling me you know
the market tells you a lot of
information whether or not you want to
use it again is up to you so you know
that's this short video you know I hope
you found it useful
you know subscribe to the channel and
you don't be interested in order flow
software be sure to click on the link
below so bye bye everyone